thank you kirsten for that story wow
that was incredible right to see all
those people again sometimes you don't
get that opportunity to thank people for
what they did for you kudos to that
medical team yes and it's incredible
they changed lives there and since we're
on the mother's day theme i thought i'd
show pictures of our mom yeah because we
have messages for mom take a look right
now guys of course uh
i love this graphic because it looks
like my refrigerator home right
is that you look how look at this
baby
happy mother's day i got our messages
there we have four the mine says sorry
about the weather mom okay and i always
use that picture oh my god ted you were
cute
what happened no you're so cute
i'm going to send a baby picture that's
cute
look how great my mom that's a good head
of hair buddy wow i'll tell you though
she likes me showing this picture every
single time because i'll get this little
romper of this little always wants me to
show that picture
any time that's for you mom
all right happy mother's day to all the
moms out there 89 degrees for summerlin
94 centennial hills 95 downtown east
side coming to 97 degrees sunrise manor
96 green valley rhodes ranch at 92
degrees and 97 for henderson yes it's
warm out there very warm that means
we're gonna have a warm evening if
you're going to be out tonight leave the
jacket at home all right 106 tomorrow or
i should say right now for death valley
that's how hot it is out there 199 for
laughlin you reached the century mark
today 95 boulder city satellite and
radar clouds and a few sprinkles up to
the north look at that while we remain
dry here do we just dodge these this is
all coming ahead of that system right
there that's going to be impacting it is
impacting the pacific northwest tracking
to the north giving us those southwest
winds tomorrow so it will be windy got a
deep trough out here out in the pacific
that's going to slide in and be around
for the next few days and into next week
and that's going to keep us cool next
week too uh high or winds for tomorrow
windy in the afternoon all right we'll
we have breezy winds early on but we'll
get the stronger winds we think later on
the afternoon but i want to show you
your mom's day forecast this is
specifically for mother's day on sunday
so hour by hour 7 a.m to 11 p.m it will
be breezy in the morning a little gusty
at times but the real winds come by
midday and the afternoon all right that
wind advisory starts right here i should
say the high wind watch starts right
here so if you're going to do any plans
do them in the morning still a little
breezy and gusty
but again dinnertime plans expect those
winds to be very strong in the afternoon
along with blowing dust 72 degrees
tonight warm for the evening that's your
forecast for the morning hours so breezy
tonight that morning starts going to
feel great for that morning walk with
the dog 93 degrees tomorrow becoming
windy tomorrow like we talked about
those gusts between 30 to 40 but we show
you the stronger gusts will come on
sunday 66 mount charleston tomorrow when
you cool up there gusts up to 45 lake
mead not a good boating day tomorrow
we'll expect choppy water 97 degrees
windy and hot eight day forecast shows a
cooling trend beginning on
sunday look at that back to the 80s and
then 70s for next week along with breezy
winds that's your most accurate forecast
have a great night back to you guys